Sorry, I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, sorry.
I just got out of the shower, so I'm like, extra, like, relaxed right now.
Oh my god, I heard myself.
You guys might have heard myself laughing there.
Oh, I forgot to mute.
I forgot to mute my Chrome.
Anyway, I just... I got... Okay, so, yeah.
I feel, like, fucking disgusting earlier.
So, for those who don't know, I was at dance lessons today for my concert.
That's happening next month.
And, like, it was a three-plus-hour session.
And I also accidentally doxed myself to this dance t-shirt now.
So, both dance t-shirts know who I am now.
I fucked up.
How did I dox myself, you might ask?
Well, so, in Canada, the thing is, in Canada, we have these things, like, to transfer money.
We don't have Venmo.
We don't use Venmo.
You can... We have this thing called e-transfer.
And you can e-transfer to, like, electronically transfer money from your bank account to another Canadian bank account's bank account without, like, Venmo.
And stuff like that.
So, what I... You know, I used my business bank account because, you know, tax write-off.
You know, because of tax write-offs.
So, because I was like, this is clearly a business expense.
What I forgot to do was that I have two business accounts.
One is... Name is DokiBird.
The other one is just numbers.
I accidentally used the DokiBird account to e-transfer to her.
And then, because, like, I didn't realize she sort of, like...
Because, like, that was the last time I, like...
Because the other... The first time I paid the lessons, I didn't use that account.
But the last time I paid her, I accidentally used the DokiBird account.
So, she was like...
Because, like, she was like, alright, yeah, do you need an invoice?
And I was like, yeah, I need an invoice.
And she's like, what do you want me to put it as?
Like, DokiBird?
And I... Literally, I was just like...
I'm just like...
Because I was like...
So...
No, no, she's young.
I'm pretty sure she googled me.
Because she was like, man, it must be so exhausting to, like, stream all the time.
Like, she was, like, having, like, small talk.
She's young.
You know how... Okay, so, like, she knows, like...
She knows gaming and stuff.
She plays League, guys.
She plays Overwatch.
Her favorite YouTubers are Slimecicle and Jschlatt.
I think she knows now.
Okay,
so...
Okay, story time.
Um, story time.
Anyway, so, when I went to dance lessons today...
She was, like, wearing, like, sunglasses.
And we're inside, by the way.
So I was like...
No, that was not the story.
So, like, she was wearing sunglasses.
And I was really confused because I was like, why is she wearing sunglasses?
And she was also wearing, like, Crocs and pajama pants.
So I was like, oh my God, is she hungover?
Like, for my dance lessons, for my very...
For my last dance lessons before I have to, like, you know, travel to America.
And I was just like, oh my God, like, is she hungover?
And then, so I was like, what happened?
And she's like, I got a concussion two days ago.
And so, I was just like...
What?
And...
She's like, yeah, I got a concussion two days ago.
And I was like, wait, why?
I'm just, like, thinking, like, why are you here?
Like, why are you working?
And so, yeah, because she had, like, a performance two days ago.
And she apparently, not even while she was performing, it was when she was gonna grab her stuff.
And basically, she was like, she apparently tripped over a bag and then slammed into the window.
Like, the bottom of the window.
And then, so she had a concussion.
And then, so then... But then, she went to work the next day.
And she's like, yeah, anyway, I went to rehearsal yesterday.
Like, I, you know, I had to wear sunglasses while doing the dance rehearsal and stuff like that.
Because the lights were starting to get... Were too bright.
So I knew I had, like, a concussion.
And then, I was like, wait, did you went to the photo shoot for your dance?
And she was like, yeah, I did.
And I had to, like, put on makeup on some of the girls and stuff.
Like, the day after her concussion!
And I was like...
I was like, am I...
Am I misunderstanding what concussion is?
I'm just, like, thinking in my head.
I'm like...
Do I just not know what concussions are?
I thought, you know, you'd be in the hospital.
Or, like, you know.
And she's like, well, I gotta work, you know.
Like, I still have to work and...
I didn't... Like, the dance teacher... Like, I was like, this is the dance teacher?
Like, your dance coach knows you have a concussion?
And she was like, yeah, he was there when you saw me hit my head.
I'm just like, oh my god!
I'm just...
Anyway...
But, like, you know, he saw me with my sunglasses and he, like...
He, like, closed the lights for me, for my dance practice.
For me during our rehearsal.
So it was, like, really nice that he did that.
And I was like, I felt like... I was just thinking, like...
I was like, why didn't you...
Why didn't you...
I was just thinking, like...
I'm just, like...
Like, why...
Why didn't you go?
Why didn't he send you home?
And she's just like, yeah, like...
Like, you know...
You know, I can't just miss the rehearsal.
Since, like, I still have to know the set and everything.
It's wasting time.
It's, like, wasting the entire team's time.
I'm like, oh my god!
And then, so...
So, it's because...
You know how...
She canceled the lesson yesterday because I was in Minecraft?
So...
So, she canceled the lesson yesterday because I was in Minecraft.
And she was telling me how...
Oh, yeah, like, you know, after I waited for, like...
Like, an hour, I figured to just leave so I could go to my rehearsal yesterday.
And, like, you know...
Make sure that I'm okay.
Like, you know, just get myself ready mentally with this concussion for my rehearsal.
Just because, like, you know, I have to, you know...
Because, like, you know, I have a headache and everything.
And, like, lights are too bright.
So, I just wanted to make sure I'm, like, mentally prepared for the back-to-back rehearsals on that yesterday.
I was just, like, what the fuck?
So, I'm just thinking, like...
You have a concussion?
Like, that's all I could think.
I was just, like, all I could think was, like...
You have a concussion?
And after, you know, and then...
And then, like, during...
Like, after the dance lessons, she's, like...
She was telling me, like, Oh, yeah, I'm gonna be heading to my Magic the Gathering group later after this lesson.
And I was, like, you can still play Magic the Gathering after this?
Like...
I'm just...
I'm just, like, what do you mean you're gonna go play Magic the Gathering after this?
She was telling me, like, she has, like, a headache.
And, like, she fucking slammed her head against the bottom of the windowsill.
You know, like, the little...
The bump at the bottom of the...
Yeah, so...
Yeah, and then she was, like, Yeah, but, like, I organized this, like, you know, we have a group chat.
And usually, we play on Sunday and everything.
So, yeah, like, you know, I am heading over to play Magic the Gathering right after this lesson.
And I'm just...
She was, like, telling me how she has a headache and, like, she's getting dizzy while doing some of the moves and everything.
And I'm, like, and you're gonna play fucking Magic the Gathering?
So, um...
That's my...
That's my, uh, story time for today.
I...
Anyway, I was, like, so mentally done after the lesson.
I was so fucking tired.
But, uh, I forgot to realize that, uh...
I realized that, like, when I got home after lessons, uh...
I forgot to buy, like, essential stuff for traveling.
So, I couldn't go to the shower right away.
So, I had to, like, uh...
Oh, I missed story time.
Don't worry, because we're on Twitch, you can actually rewatch VODs, by the way.
So, like, lucky for you, we're on Twitch for today.
So, you can go back to click the VOD and rewatch story time.
Um, so, like, I had to go out and buy, like, you know, a microphone and everything and, like, travel stuff.
Um, because, like, I don't...
I don't have time to unpack as well.
Like, I don't know if I packed my other microphone that I used for, uh...
I don't know if I packed my old microphone that I used when I used to travel.
So, then I'm, like, um...
I might as...
I'll just buy a new one.
Just because, like, I don't have...
I don't know.
There's, like, 15 plus boxes.
And I don't have time to unpack that.
So, I bought some, like, travel stuff.
Um, some travel stuff for myself.
Uh, just for...
Just for...
Uh, just because, like, uh...
You know, I don't know if I have any of these things.
So...
Uh, yeah.
I was shopping when I asked for a microphone.
Because, like, I was heading there anyway.
So, I was just, like, alright.
Let's see what...
Let's see what I can get that's in this store right now.
So, yeah.
And I grabbed...
I grabbed, uh...
I grabbed, like, dinner on back...
On the way back.
And then I went to take a shower.
Because I felt fucking disgusting.
You know?
Right after dance lessons, I couldn't shower right away.
And it was, like, three hours of dancing.
So, I was just, like...
Um...
I was just, like, oh, fuck.
I need a...
I need...
Because, like...
A lot...
It's Sunday, too.
It's the worst day to be shopping.
It's Sunday.
Like...
I don't...
And I know...
I know I don't have time to buy equipment stuff tomorrow.
So, I was just, like...
Oh, my God.
It's Sunday.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I...
I need to get there before...
Before places close.
Um...
Anyway, I was...
I, like, fucking hibernated so hard yesterday.
I think, like...
I was, like, I'm gonna take a nap.
Even though I know I have, like, a lot of stuff to do.
I'm gonna take a nap.
And I think I slept, like, 10 plus...
Like, I slept all the way till my dance lesson.
And then, I was so fucking mentally...
I was, like, when...
Like, during the lessons, the teacher was, like, Are you okay?
Cause I was staring at the wall for, like, 30 seconds.
During one...
During the middle of it.
Like, before I...
Before we were gonna do another run.
I was just, you know, like, wore PTSD.
I was just, like...
And the teacher was, like, Are you okay?
And I'm just, like, Sorry, I was disassociating.
Oh, my God.
I'm okay, by the way.
I was just mentally so tired by then.
I was, like...
Oh, my God.
Yesterday was just a lot.
Anyway.
So.
Why am I doing gorilla...
Uh...
Isn't it great, guys?
The best part is that I'm already in the rust category.
So, with...
So, even though rust is not up on my...
Up on the screen right now.
You're still getting the AK at the moment.
The AK...
It still adds on to the AK.
Huge shout-out for Sakuno for fucking grinding the drops for me.
It was just very poor timing from my end.
Anyway.
Also, uh...
Oh, my God.
Shout-out to Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
So.
For those who don't know.
I have an exclusive AK rust drop.
Uh...
And...
I shall try to stream at least two hours.
I don't know.
Because, like, I know Gumi is not online today.
Because she's actually traveling as well.
So, she's, like, busy doing whatever Gumi does.
Um...
When she's not streaming.
So, it's solo hours for me.
So, it's a little intimidating.
Um...
Because I'm by myself this time.
And...
Um...
You know...
That's...
It's, like, a little intimidating.
Because I'm by myself.
And I'm like...
What do I do?
Mmm...
Interaction is scary.
Um...
But yes, all you have to do is watch until...
Watch until, you know, you get your drop.
Or stay after you get your drop.
It's really up to...
It's up to you.
Um...
So that's why I'm doing Guru's stream.
Because, you know.
It's a very...
It's always a great opportunity to show, like...
It's a very, you know, fortunate position to be in to be part of the Exclusive streamer rush drop because not a lot of streamers get picked for this So I was like, all right, I got it.
I got it.
You know, at least stream more than Kai Sinat.
I'm sorry.
That was That was a low ball
I'm sorry Kai.
I love your contents really great.
I just thought it was funny
That's like my goal is to make sure I at least do more rust hours
I just I felt really bad because I was like, oh this is it's so hard to get bit like, you know There's such a great.
It's such a you know, fortunate position to be in and then I am I am going to be away to to practice for my concert this week and So I was like, ah, fuck.
Okay, I need And you know, a lot of Dragoons, you guys want the 8k as well And so I'm gonna try and try and stream for at least two to three hours today And then I'll stream again while on my laptop.
I hope my laptop can run rust.
If not, I don't know I don't know.
So I'm gonna try to stream as much as as much as I can maybe like one or two more times during my vacation and Not vacation.
It's not vacation.
It's work during Why am I saying vacation during my work trip my business trip?
So we'll see we'll see Dad thank you for the twitch prime.
Thank you.
Let me put up rust now All right, time to boot up rust All right, let's see Is that great already like you're half you're you're like one fourth away from the drop because and rust has not even been pulled up yet Rust hasn't even been pulled up yet.
And you're already one fourth away.
I Heard after I left the first session A war broke out between the Lurklings and Shroud's Kingdom, which I was like how?
What happened?
Hey guys, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
And then Gumi Gumi ditched the Lurklings and joined Shroud's kingdom Before the war broke out.
So now she's like in his kingdom now I was like, why are you not in the Lurklings anymore?
Like after I left?
Oh My god, look, I'm not away.
You can't scan see I don't have to came up yet.
I was gonna be like, oh my god Guys, look Where's my gun?
rock Guys, we're the that's me I'm a fish.
I'm on officially on the website.
I'm not the way on the loading screen on the main menu guys, look Screenshot this screenshot this gap.
Not this part.
Not this this one screenshot
Oh my god, i'm officially part of rust Okay, uh, there's f5 right?
Yeah All right connecting What the fuck happened while I was gone is ak Is ak like available yet chat?
Maybe we should just go gambling.
I I stole for a thousand Scrap anyway, or or I saw a thousand or so from that one guy I just hope I don't lose it while I head over to gambling.
Um Let's go gambling It's or right not scrap I don't remember was it or scrap that I stole From that one guy that I killed and then they're like i'm still missing my stuff And then you know, and then they never knew it was me.
They never knew How would they know?
Oh my god, I don't hope I don't die I I What do I do with or chat what do I even do with or like I I don't know I'm, like a rust noob
What do I do with it, I know it's valuable because they got really angry um They got really angry about it being missing because I sold a thousand of it They never expected me.
It was me though But what can I craft though Or and it's like what can I craft I'm a baby God I hope there's no bears I hope there's no bears to ruin my day but I think at best I might I might only stream for like Two hours because i'm like very tired I'm so tired.
Oh, wait.
What time is my flight?
Wait, sorry, I forgot what time my flight was give me a That's important.
That is very important Um Let's see.
Um Where's the where's the phantom thief group chat?
Okay Phantom thief.
Okay What is what is?
My flight hours what time Fuck okay Okay All right.
Okay.
It's that okay.
All right.
It's a lot earlier than I remembered
Okay My look at all of us sleeping
What the fuck why is blao red now, huh?
Poor guy
What the wait, what's what's going on just got on I just woke up from my long sleep We were attacked by who?
Who were we attacked by What the fuck happened?
Oh my god.
I was in a coma.
I was in a fucking coma Wait What's going on?
Follow me.
Wait.
I have a lot of stuff on me though.
Do I do I bank it?
Don't worry.
Bring it.
Okay
Oh what happened when did all this happen and I was how long have I been asleep It's all about that ride Oh what We are our stuff is still there well, oh, by the way, I forgot to close the door to our base by the way It's fine grab our stuff and go
Wait, how long have I been asleep?
They said it was okay they said it was okay.
Oh my god Why do we have three trains?
What what well they took my suit I'm going naked That was pretty scary
They tamed the metal serpents Why
Wait, that means coco and them are gonna have the advantage on them Oh my god, how do I get up what's going on?
I don't have an extra one who it was, you know, what happened hungry I was gone for two days.
Yeah, I got an extra as well if somebody need
I was gone for 20 years Yeah I was in a coma for 20 years.
I was in a coma for 20 years and everything changed
I finally woke up.
What's going on?
What happened?
There's an armory get weapons War
Come come to this training we're not taking those two Everyone get on the train trust me
Wait for one What yeah, I need some food anyone did I Wait a minute.
Why am I naked?
Wait who killed me?
All right, go ahead go go go go
I Think they found out who stole them.
I think they found out who stole the loot guys
Wait what
Wait That is not enough
How many must die for 10?
Who the fuck is 10?
I need to get some clothes.
I need... oh my god.
Who the fuck is... I'm just... I'm...
Why do we have a cold now?
Why do we have a cold?
I'm naked.
Apparently 10 is someone worth killing for.
I'm just like, who are... who are all of these people?
I don't want to start.
We're gonna grab some clothes.
We're gonna... I'm just so confused.
I'm naked and I'm very afraid.
I died for a guy I don't even know.
Okay, can I... I really need clothes.
No, I shouldn't.
Small town kid got drafted.
Are we even... like, what are we doing?
I'm worried I'm gonna... alright, I just want pants.
Like, at least let me have pants at least.
At least just let me wear pants.
That's all I care.
I... bro, I just...
Who... who's 10?
Why are we... why is everyone fighting for 10?
10!
What happened?
Who is he?
Is it like, save 10, save the world?
Is that it?
Is it like a prophecy?
Is he like...
He's like the chosen one?
Like, we're going for war for 10.
There is only... he is the chosen one, Toki.
You don't understand.
I have... I have... I have zero context here.
But we must protect 10.
Oh my god.
For 10, we must protect...
And no one else has 10.
And 10 we trust.
Wait, I should get a weapon.
You're right.
What darkness do we need?
We have so many people fighting for 10!
Like...
Wait, did you die?
Better off 10, like...
Okay, I gotta know what changed in our world.
Like, what...
Like, I felt like...
Nothing's the same anymore.
Nothing's the same.
Everything is new and I'm so afraid.
I need to find the lore master.
The 10 lore master.
This is the time skip arc.
This is the time skip that I fucking missed out on.
I'm just gonna check.
Okay, the check on stuff.
Oh man.
Yeah, I'm trying to see, like, what's changed.
What's new?
I feel like I was in a coma.
And, like, we time skipped.
I know you've been in a coma, but...
Okay, whoa, whoa, relax, okay?
You were in a coma, okay?
Just breathe.
It's like we're in different clothes now.
Like, we were, like, simple vikings.
Are we even still vikings?
Like, what are we?
Yo, breathe.
Take it slow, okay?
Don't panic, okay?
Don't panic.
A lot has happened.
Take it slow.
Breathe in, breathe out.
One more time.
Still the same, man.
Are we?
You ended up in a coma.
What happened?
Are we?
I don't know.
I closed my eyes.
And then, it's like, everything's different.
We had one house.
Oh, boy.
What happened?
Listen, that's a long story.
How many wars has there been?
Come with me.
Don't come with me.
Come with him, Lord Master.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's Ted.
Wait, is that the Ted?
Is that him?
Is he Ted?
Ted, Ted, come with me.
Come.
Come, come, come, come.
Mateo, what's going on?
Hey, guys.
That's the guy I'm supposed to protect?
You're the guy we're supposed to protect?
Come up here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are you trying to say, man?
You know, when everybody was telling me to, like...
Sit down, sit down.
To protect Ted, you know, I had a different image of who Ted is.
Come on, man.
I had a different image of Ted.
Just turn off your torch.
Alright, listen, Toki.
Okay.
You know, a lot has happened since, you know, what is it, the past three days.
But all you can know for now, the reason Ted is being wanted and why they want him back so bad is because he used to be one of them.
One of who?
Who are you part of?
The people that just...
I was part of the House of Awaken.
The House of Awaken?
Yeah.
Wait, why did you leave?
Because they wanted to be with Dakin.
They just wanted to be with Dakin.
Now that they've realized what they've lost, they want him back.
And they want him back in blood.
And they're willing, you guys, they're willing to kill hundreds of innocent people for you?
What the...
Dakin, she's making fun of you, man.
No, I'm not, I just...
I'm not, no, no, no, no, no, I'm not making...
Are you jealous?
No, I'm not making fun of him.
No, I'm just saying.
I'm just saying.
You are the chosen one.
I'm just like...
I'm just saying.
Look, I just...
I never met the Ted before, so I need context here.
Like, I just need to know, like...
Why are they...
Why is the House of whatever...
What's his name?
What is the...
Awaken?
Listen, Doki.
Listen, listen.
I'm the general.
I'm the lord.
Of this community.
When I tell you...
You gotta throw your body in front of Ted.
What are you gonna do?
I throw my body in front of Ted.
Exactly, exactly.
Just know he's a very valuable person.
That's gonna be very important later on.
That's all I can tell for now.
That's why I want him back.
I just realized what I've lost.
Oh my god.
He's worth more than a million scrap.
You're worth more than a million scrap?
Okay, okay, okay.
Now I sort of...
Okay.
No, no.
I'm just...
I was shocked.
I was just shocked there.
I never thought I'd see...
No, I'm just saying.
I've never seen a million...
I've never seen a million scrap before.
So it blew my mind that that was a number.
I'm jealous, huh?
You got one sibling?
You like the little...
You like the sibling that's always jealous.
No, I'm just...
Look, I was gone for so long.
And then I got like...
Everything is different and new.
And now we have Christmas lights.
Look, I...
Just...
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's a lot to take in.
I've been sleeping for three days.
So it's a lot to take in.
I get it.
I get it, honestly.
I wish I could sleep for three days.
Okay.
Okay, so...
So like...
Please sit down.
Any more questions?
So...
So like...
Is it only that house that's looking for Ted?
Or are the other houses also want Ted?
No, I think it's mostly them for now because they used to have him.
Okay.
Okay, and how...
And...
Because no one knows really the real value of that guy.
So like...
How long has this war been?
How long has this war lasted?
Okay, you might not believe it.
But it just started.
Like, you just got on probably and it just happened.
So I woke up to war.
I woke up to the Great Ted War.
Some might say...
Wait a minute.
Wait, the Great Ted War?
Yeah, some might say.
Some might say.
You can call it that.
I just literally woke up and got drafted.
Like...
Drafted into the Great Ted War.
So who's in the house of...
The other house?
Who's in there?
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
And...
Alright.
Okay, I think I got enough context now.
I think I have enough context.
What?
What happened?
Was it for her?
Wait, for like, love life.
I thought you said you have a love life.
Or for him.
You know, I don't judge.
Was it for him?
Was it for Ted?
He left his house for you.
Wasn't that...
Okay.
Who left what?
I said, Ted.
Didn't Ted leave his house for you?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
He took his nap.
I still haven't woken up.
But...
He said he wanted to see it tomorrow, which was today.
But I also told Janet that I made this room for her.
Oh!
And she also wants to see it today.
Right?
So...
Boom.
I'm in a dilemma, right?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I promised two people that I made a special room.
Right?
I made a special room, which is the same room.
Yeah.
You know what any other normal person would do?
What would they do?
Make the exact same house.
So I have two of the exact same house with the exact same room.
Wait, what?
Like I have both of them, or like each of them in each house.
But what if they come to each of the house at the same time?
What you gonna do?
No, no, no.
It won't happen.
So, look, look.
So, you see this?
Yeah.
The fireplace?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come with me.
He made the exact same house for two different people.
I'm just thinking the amount of time.
Wait, is this the other one?
Oh, it's unfinished.
What the fuck?
How the fuck do I...
Just jump, jump.
Oh, jump here.
Okay.
You don't need to...
Oh, shit.
This is trippy.
Okay, this is pretty trippy.
So, which one is Janet's place and which one is Foolish's place?
This one is Foolish.
This one is for Foolish?
This is the original one.
The OG?
Okay.
Wait, then why is the other one better?
Why is the other one more well-built?
Because I'm a changed man now.
Oh, so you're trying to say Janet is a higher tier than Foolish.
No, no, no.
So you care about her more than him.
That's what I'm saying.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Now you're putting just word in my mouth.
Yeah, okay, okay.
I'm on my winter arc now.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm not proceeding love anymore.
I need to love myself first.
Oh, so you already broke up with him.
I've called it off.
Oh, so what are you going to do with these two houses now?
I'm not sure yet.
I mean, this is Foolish's house.
He's living downstairs.
Oh, so he took the house in the divorce.
I see.
I mean, originally it was his.
I just, you know, I just moved in.
Oh, there he is.
Wow.
He's got one house, guys.
Foolish took the house in the divorce.
What do you think?
Wait, who said that?
Hello?
Hi, I got some of your stuff.
Here's your phone.
Oh, thank you very much.
Now he's just laughing.
You're fighting for him?
Look at him!
They stole your phone, Tete.
This is the guy I'm supposed to put my body on line for?
Look at him!
Gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen.
Hello?
What's up?
Who is this?
I just want to make sure they're doing okay.
Me at the rock.
Hello?
Why do you have Tete's phone?
Be ready.
I don't, you know...
Wait, I don't have any arrows or a bow.
I don't speak London, what are you saying?
Everything is over here.
Oh, okay.
I don't speak London.
Everything that you need is all in two chests.
Okay.
I mean, I remember when I went to bed and we had one house.
If you need more, uh...
If you need more sleeping bags, there's also more in there too.
Okay, okay.
You're gonna need it to...
You're gonna need...
Oh, this house?
The golden chest?
Two chests right in front of you.
Okay.
Where are the arrows?
Oh, is it in the other chest?
Right here.
I took it back.
Okay, okay.
I got the arrows.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Arrows, bandages, swords, bows, armor, sleeping bags...
What the fuck happened?
What the...
What the fuck?
What happened?
Oh, if you need food...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where's the food?
Right here.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
And water.
I just...
Easy.
I fucking...
I thought it would be the simple life.
I thought we were living the simple life.
This is no longer simple.
This is no longer the simple life anymore.
This is no longer...
I don't even think we're vikings anymore.
Wait, what is this picture?
Listen, man.
Alright?
Listen.
Listen, man.
Alright?
There's always gonna be one thing that we always have that no one else has.
We have like...
The scouting area?
We...
We got to find it.
Nobody else has.
I'm now part of the kingdom of Ted?
What is that?
What the fuck?
I remember when we were just vikings.
I remember...
I remember when we were...
From Odin to Ted.
Things changed.
And then I fucking woke up.
I woke up to...
I woke up to get drafted for a war that I didn't even want to be part of.
You guys all saw Ted!
I'm supposed to fight for...
I'm supposed to give my life to that guy?
I...
Wait, what are you trying to say, Dokiha?
You don't like Ted?
Is that what...
All I'm saying is that when I...
When I was...
When I was told...
Of like...
A man we're fighting for today...
I...
I had a different vision of what Ted would look like.
I had a very different vision of Ted.
It was...
Like, I'm just saying...
This was not who I thought Ted would be.
This was absolutely...
Never meet your...
Never meet your heroes, Doki.
What's that down there?
He's blue once he talks.
What's going on?
What?
Finally someone with a higher IQ than a door.
Finally.
Yeah, the other guy that had the phone, he wasn't...
He wasn't the brightest.
All he was doing was like making noise.
I don't know.
I couldn't understand.
What the fuck is going on?
What?
What is...
What is going on?
Anyway, I gotta head over.
It would be funny if I killed Ted.
It would be very funny.
I feel like...
What makes Ted... I'm not jealous, guys.
I'm not jealous of Ted.
I'm just saying, like...
He's not even...
He's not even like... He wasn't even part of the group on day one.
Guys.
He wasn't even part of the group on day one.
I'm not jealous.
He's not... He was not... He wasn't even from here.
He wasn't even from here.
Where is everybody?
Wait, where is everybody?
Ted is... You just met him!
Guys!
You just met Ted!
Now we want to protect him.
I can't believe it, guys.
God, if I see Ted...
It would be a shame if there was an accident.
Yeah, no.
Dakin filled me in on...
Dakin told me about the great Ted war.
So, like...
Are we gonna... Are we gonna get invaded?
Like, are we...
What happened?
How did Ted come here?
I'm gonna be honest with you, guys.
If any of the kingdoms want to invade us and just...
You know, foundation wipe us, I mean, they could.
So, I really hope they don't.
But...
More importantly...
Cloud doesn't even have an accent anymore!
He...
He doesn't even...
He turned American!
He got educated!
In three days, he got a degree!
He got colonized.
What the fuck?
What's up, guys?
What's up, Steven?
We have a chance to redeem ourselves, though.
A chance for...
Action, thrill, and bloodlust.
The Church of the Blood God rides north to attack House Pargarion.
House Pargarion, of all the houses, is our most mortal enemy.
I share no love for them.
I hate them more than anyone.
Except for maybe House Horkonen now at this point, because they're...
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna pause the Game of Thrones music to just kind of vent a little bit of saltiness.
I thought it was insane that they...
No, no, no.
I'm gonna... I need to let a little bit of salt out.
They put down wooden barricades in a fight against us when we have bows.
Is that machine guns?
And they're that serious?
Like, we're dressed as fucking wildlings and they're throwing down barricades?
Like, how sweaty do you have to be?
Holy shit!
I mean, it is war, so...
Hey, talk!
No presidente, just talk.
Get off me!
I share no love for House Pogarian.
I hate them more than anything.
Speech!
And what about our...
But you know what I love more than my hatred for House Pogarian?
Is my love for the North.
And we will defend the North.
If anyone tries to destroy us in the North, it is House Pogarian, for one of us will defeat the other eventually, but I will not let the Church of the Blood God be the ones to take our mortal enemies from us.
So, on this day, we will walk to the gates of House Pogarian.
They will let us up onto the ramparts.
The first wave of attack we will hold off from up there, and then we will spawn in at the rock here with more arrows.
And we will harass the Blood God as they try to attack.
And I'm running out of things to say.
You get the point!
I wish you get the point!
How big is their army?
Are we with them?
It doesn't matter how big their army are.
We're fighting a church!
It doesn't matter who destroys it.
What matters is the noise.
It matters that we don't have guns, though.
One of us is worth tens and thousands of them, alright?
That's how we need to move forward.
We should consider using guns!
Guns?
No.
We don't use guns.
It is so loose!
Say the word!
Maybe not now, maybe not now.
Hold on.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I think they have tier 2.
Guys, don't say that!
We're gonna destroy religion!
We're gonna convert them to our religion.
Do we even have a religion anymore?
Is our religion just Ted?
Some of us.
Wait, okay.
Do they have...
Is the AK ready yet?
Wait, guys.
Do they have AKs yet?
Does the church have AKs?
You don't know what's going on!
Does the church have...
I just need to know.
Does the church have AKs?
That's...
That would change...
That would be...
Not yet?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna wait until one of the squads have AKs.
So who are we fighting?
The lord has blessed Michael.
No, not yet, guys.
No.
We don't betray them yet.
Not yet.
Until we get the AK, then I'll think about it, chat.
Until...
Until we have the AK.
The far left, there is an open gate we can enter.
Me and my bow.
How did I end up joining the one fucking team that doesn't have...
That does not use guns for my gun drop?
How did I...
Only Doki.
There's like five different...
Read...
Five...
Five plus different tribes going on here.
And I still haven't managed to join the one tribe that doesn't use guns.
You let go of your fucking arrow.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Just shoot at whatever you see.
Pause.
What?
We go south.
Oh.
Come.
Oh, we go south?
Where are we heading?
Okay, you need to decide.
Look, look, look.
No, no, we go, we go...
Listen, listen.
Okay, change of plans.
I'm so sorry.
I just realized.
I don't think the Blood God Church is going to attack Paugarion.
What?
Where did you get your intel?
They're attacking Warchonin.
Wait, why don't...
From all these people.
They're attacking Warchonin.
Wait, are we going to be working together with the Blood Church?
We're going to make it a revenge.
No.
We're attacking Warchonin for revenge.
Yeah, so we're working together with the Blood God.
It's not the same thing.
You know, we're...
Yeah, we'll kill them afterwards.
They're just like, wait a minute.
We hate everyone.
We don't hate.
They're like, no, that's different.
Shoot them.
The captain stopped.
He's moving again.
He's on the move.
Not allies.
Just we both hate the same people.
We just both hate the same people.
It's not the same, guys.
It's not the same.
I can't believe so much happened.
There's fucking New Zealand in the night?
He stopped again.
He stopped.
Hold.
He's on the go.
He's moving.
He's getting a message from the gods.
What are the gods telling you, Val?
I wish we have medals.
I wish we have medal seeds, guys.
Just pause and he's like, sorry, I'm getting a message real quick.
Thanks for the intel, guys.
Thank you for the intel.
It's actually crazy.
So now not only do we have a war for Ted.
We've got a telephone in the base.
Is that?
Landline.
Yeah, I do kind of want to take it down at a moment's notice.
Wait, so like we hate everything metal, but phones.
And a few others selected.
With exceptions.
To a solar panel on the roof.
But I mean.
Don't worry about it.
Metal sucks, but phones though, chat.
Phones.
Phones are different.
An AK should have been an exception.
That's all I'm saying.
They really are the Amish.
Do you know the Amish use phones like iPhones now?
Oh my God.
I somehow became Amish.
Yeah, no, they do.
Yes, the Amish.
The Amish have like used phones.
Yeah, it's loud apparently.
The Amish with exceptions.
Does he know that?
I've seen an Amish with an iPhone and they like threw me off.
It was so fucking weird.
There's a specific sector?
There's different sectors of Amish?
Which Amish?
Wait, I thought the Amish were just the Amish.
I live near an Amish community.
Walking through Wal- They go to Walmart?
I thought they grow and make- Wait, what?
They go to Walmart now?
They love- What are they doing at Walmart?
What are they- What are they fucking Tupperware?
Are they buying Tupperware?
Like-
I didn't know.
I didn't know they would go to fucking Walmart.
There was an Amish patch notes.
The fucking Amish patch notes that I didn't read about.
Oh.
Who are they?
Who are they, bro?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
30 seconds.
Oh, this game.
Oh, my God.
I can't.
We actually call a fucking Uber.
We - Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Fucking New Zealand runs a- Runs a taxi- Runs an Uber service.
Where are we head- Are we heading to Walmart?
What about poop?
Can I have poop?
Fuck.
I need to take a shit.
Oh, please.
Take a shit.
I think- I'm pretty sure- Oh, fuck.
Who's eating my shit?
This has been a weird day, guys.
This has been a weird day.
Why did I ever wake up from my coma?
I feel like I'm already in economy.
I feel like I'm already in economy now, guys.
This must be what it's like to fly in economy.
Three minutes show.
Oh,
no.
Please.
Are there any-
I should have walked, guys.
I should have walked.
I'm thinking about jumping right now.
The temptation is growing by the second.
Oh,
my God.
Everything is so different above here.
Let's see.
Where did we- Where are we?
Well- Isn't that- Appreciate you, brother.
Wait, isn't that father- Isn't that one of the blood god people over there?
Over- Yeah, that's- He's just standing there looking at us.
Wait, that's him.
He disappeared.
I like
how he just looked at us.
Where did he go?
Are we preparing for a war right now?
Wait, there he is.
You think- You ever think God has forsaken you?
Sometimes.
What the fuck is going on?
Guys, I think-
Guys, I think Twinkles is getting tempted.
I think-
I think I just witnessed a conversion right now.
Where's the last one at?
Can you close all the doors?
We might need some beds.
Yeah, I need a bed.
I need a bed.
How many beds do we need?
Rock always wins.
Wait, is this Mendo?
It's fucking-
He'll give up one day.
He's gonna give up soon.
There's no way.
He's gonna stop.
Rock always wins.
We're in the middle of the war and he's gonna fucking stop.
Oh, Rock.
This is the real war.
We mean as smart.
Rock always wins.
What are you talking about?
Then why am I not winning?
Shit.
I told you.
Rock always wins.
Not a believer.
You just weren't a believer.
Mentally.
I'm just mentally stronger than you.
Wait, what's up, Mendo?
We need some epic music, man.
We need some epic music.
Okay.
Guys, half of us have fucking bow and arrows.
Get down with that, Mendo.
Why did it stop?
Keep going.
That should be the music to war.
Did you get converted?
I saw you talking to him.
Do you have food, Abby?
Oh, really?
He was second-guessing the blood guy?
What's his name?
Billy's not gonna like that.
Go, baby.
The priest fell on a pan and died.
People who love fishing?
You mean, like, fish fish?
I meant, like, fish?
Yeah, men who love fishing.
We're going bottom right.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
We're shooting.
Son of a bitch.
I didn't set up a bed.
We have 85 satchels.
I hope you brought yours as well.
I didn't bring any sleeping bags, guys.
I didn't bring any sleeping bags.
T-21.
What the fuck?
I didn't...
No!
What the fuck?
I can't believe...
The hour... The time I got on for Russ is, like, the great fucking war is starting.
What are the odds?
What are the fucking odds that a war has fucking started?
When I got on.
We're gonna fucking take a kingdom, apparently.
I'm gonna be part of history, chat!
I shall be part of history!
Okay, okay.
Good, good.
Which side of history?
That's true.
Which...
Which... Wait.
Does anyone...
Does any... Anyone have extra?
What part?
Which side?
Blood don't grow on trees.
I'm, like, in the Hunger Games.
Blood God's gonna take me.
I'm in the fucking Hunger Games shit.
How are the fish today?
Pretty good?
We're just passing through, just a little...
Yeah, it's the monthly, uh, fun run.
It's just the monthly fun run, don't mind us.
Just the fucking fishermen!
We passed the fucking fishermen!
Man, he loves fishing!
There he is!
There's one of the men that love fishing!
I got blood and pay to the shrine today.
The Blood God's gonna kill me.
There ain't no rest for the Blood God.
Blood don't grow on trees.
I got blood and pay, bills to pay.
The Blood God's gonna kill me.
Bro, I'm fucking... This is a jam.
You gotta release this, actually, on Spotify.
Like, that should actually be on Spotify!
Wait, where was
the island?
What the fuck?
Why didn't we not take the Uber to, like, get closer?
Why didn't we take that Uber?
Clearly, we have to take that Uber instead of running all the way here.
Not have money?
Fuck.
Dude, what the fuck?
Oh,
shit!
It's starting!
Oh my God, they're already starting!
The war is starting!
Wait, does anyone have extra bags?
Is someone get my gun?
I'm broke.
Oh my God.
Wait, does anyone have extra bags?
I don't have extra bags, guys.
This is bad!
Where is Blau?
I'm fucking lost and confused.
Guys, look at, like, how many people there are here.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Oh my God, a rocket ship.
What do I wanna name it?
Help me.
Try to figure it out.
It's so funny.
Oh my God, we gotta go this way.
But no one came to help.
Not shoot them.
Oh my God.
There they are.
There he is.
Oh my God, we have bows and arrows!
How did he down them?
They're so far...
Bojack vs.
Hemlock.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, what is this?
What war did we get into?
The old Viking...
The old Viking ways.
Is that...
Is he...
Sorry, you look just like them!
Yeah, yeah, you were running at him!
You were next to him!
Why were you next to him?
Don't worry, I took the arrows out.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, don't worry.
You're 4k.
I took the arrows.
You gotta say something when you were getting shot at earlier.
Why didn't you say anything?
I tried.
I said something the moment I got hit by an arrow.
Honestly, I'm just observing.
I don't really know what's going on.
Yeah, me too.
I woke up...
I went to bed on the first day and then apparently I slipped into a coma and woke up today.
And now we're in a war and I got drafted in a war.
I don't know what happened either.
Yeah, I know.
I mean, somebody killed somebody.
Somebody killed somebody else.
And then they killed somebody else and then...
And now all us young people are trying to fight somebody else's war?
No, I mean, isn't that always the case?
It's all these big fancy highfalutin leaders that are...
Yeah, using us.
Making everybody fight in wars.
I don't even know what I'm fighting for anymore.
They told me I'm fighting for some guy named Ted.
Who the fuck is Ted?
I don't even know who that guy is.
He's part of your group, but I'm gonna be honest.
I think this whole war is over nothing.
I've been inside the drama here.
Were you part of... Did you watch everything unfold from the very beginning?
Everything?
Wait, you must have made a lot of money from this.
You must have capitalized it.
Yeah, so you wouldn't want the war to be over.
I have...
Why would you want the war to be over?
How are you gonna feed...
How would you feed your kids?
If the war ends?
There's always people that need balloon rides.
There's always...
Well, first of all, my kids can't eat because I keep gambling away all of my scrap.
Okay.
So...
Look, there's always people that need balloon rides.
And I'm just tired of all the death and suffering.
Yeah.
It's just too much for me to bear.
It was nice talking to you, but I think I have to go back to war.
If I see you again tomorrow...
Probably do.
Then that meant I made it.
I survived.
This might be the last you'll see me.
It's a bloodbath up there.
Goodbye, sir.
Off to war I go.
Off returning back to war.
I can't believe this all started off because of some fucking guy named Ed.
It made me your destiny.
Wow!
Who did I get shot by?
What happened?
We killed a guy with a gun.
What did we do with it?
Steal it.
Then we sell it on the black market.
For the people who like to use guns.
Oh wait, I want water.
Guys, how do I fill the water up?
How do I drink the water?
Wait, first off...
How do I...
Oh, that's how you drink it.
There you go.
Hydrate.
Remember to stay hydrated, boys.
Stay hydrated.
Yeah, I need another one.
Yeah, I got a bed ready.
No, no, I have a bed.
But it's all the way back there.
Wait,
is he...
Are these bad people?
Wait, I thought this was...
A bad person lives here?
Oh!
Woah!
They're killing her!
She's crazy.
Do we kill her?
Yeah, kill her.
She's down.
Oh my god.
There's one by our garage.
I thought you were better than that.
I thought you were better.
Fuck your dragon breath.
There's still one more.
Listen, don't loot her weapon.
Don't loot her weapon.
Can I take her clothes?
I'm just...
I'm gonna take her pants.
I need...
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
That is a lot.
Wow, that's all you, tiger.
That's all you.
I'm gonna go and die somewhere and grief them and never give it back.
It's so rare, guys.
What's so...
What's...
Oh!
It's for gunpowder.
Yes.
Yeah, no.
I got one.
I got one already.
It's like all the way back there.
There.
Where we first started the war.
I wanna go and fight.
Then go.
Go.
Fight.
Kill.
Okay, nevermind.
From above.
Above on the tower.
Heads up, you have to all warriors.
You cannot barricade.
I don't know if this will hit.
Okay, let's see.
I don't know.
Maybe here?
Does that hit?
I don't fucking know!
We're fucking shooting with bows and arrows!
Yeah, there's two guys up on the roof.
Two guys up on the roof?
Yeah, two guys up on the roof.
Was somebody on the left side here?
I don't know.
I got shot from the tower.
Yeah, he's on top of the tower.
There's somebody on the ground here.
I'm lighting it up.
Oh, don't do that.
It would be crazy if I hit this.
We may need to give up the air balloon.
We may need to give up.
When is the next church service?
We're in the middle of a fucking war!
What do you mean?
He's in front of me!
Shit!
Someone help me.
Oh my god.
Gotta get my stuff back.
Okay.
Let's head.
Why is he not part of this?
We're literally fighting for him.
Why is he part of the fight?
He's just...
And of course there's a storm while there's a war.
A fucking course there is a storm.
God, what is this fucking cinematic universe I'm in right now?
Where's my stuff?
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
Yeah, where did I die?
Where did I fucking die?
Why?
I'll never find my body!
Oh my god, there it is.
Thank god, and I still have her pants.
That I still...
Oops.
What the fuck is going on?
Wait, what?
Did they take my...
Did they take my bow?
Wait, they took my bow.
Wait, my bow got taken.
Bow is on the ground?
Oh, okay.
Fuck, oh there it is.
I got it.
Wow!
That was a shotgun!
I'm going in, I'm going in!
Oh,
he got finished!
Got you!
Where is he?
Everybody in, everybody in, everybody in.
The other way, the other way!
Get to the chopper!
You will all fall!
Your time is over!
It's over.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
What did we get?
What did we get shot down?
I got you, I'm the greatest of all time.
I'm sorry, I'm scared of heights.
Yeah, no torches.
Words for coconut, they're pushing more on the right side.
So we're pushing on the left side.
Does anyone have an extra bow by the way?
Uh, no.
I have a melee weapon.
I only have, yeah I only have one bow.
Where are we even, where are we going?
You know how to do it?
Are you sure you know how to do it?
Yes, I know how to do it.
I think we're going on the other...
Just hold on, everybody hold on.
Okay, so just hold on, we're gonna have to go real high for a second.
You can reach it from there, right?
Yeah, I got it.
We just gotta go real high to get back on course, just gotta spin around again.
We're gonna figure this out, guys.
Yeah,
we're just doing a U-turn, guys.
It's just a U-turn.
It's just a U-turn, just don't uh, don't lock the button or we're not gonna be able to keep...
We're, oh my god, we're gonna troy this?
We're about to go in!
Oh my god, this is cheating!
Guys, this is cheating!
We're de-dating this!
Are you fucking...
We're going in, we're going in!
Airdrop incoming!
Oh my god, we're...
Oh my god.
He's stuck, he's stuck!
Shadow?
Hit him one more time.
I think he DC'd.
Wait, I'll do it, I'll do it.
Wait, wait, wait, stop, stop, don't shoot, don't shoot.
There we go.
Everybody get out, everybody get out, everybody get out.
Left, left, left, left.
Oh my god, how did he DC it this time?
How did he DC?
Oh my god.
Who's with you?
Who's with us?
Is it just you?
What is going on?
Oh,
oh, okay, we're together.
We're all together, we're all together.
We shot each other!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe you shot us!
What is going on?
We shot each other!
Friendly fire, friendly fire, friendly fire!
Where are we running?
Why are we running still?
You guys just keep running, where are we going?
I don't know, I just follow.
I can't believe we friendly fired.
A fucking friendly fire!
Yes, it was all friendly fire!
They shot us and we had frozen arrows!
That's bad!
Wow, wow, wow!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
He's with us, he's with us!
What are you doing?
Oh, he's not!
Who's with us?
He's with the Lurklings!
He is, that's why they were attacking us!
He joined us!
He has joined us!
That's why we're fighting them!
You got a spy in your fucking church!
Can every Lurkling put their hands up so we know exactly who you are?
Okay, Lurklings don't have guns.
We don't even have guns!
Wait, Mendo, what do you mean he's a spy?
Guys, who's a Lurkling?
Tennis guy!
Wait, the church?
We're not in the church!
Where's your body?
I'll take his arrows, he's dead anyway.
Where are we supposed to go?
I don't even know where we're supposed to go.
Oh, we can see!
We can finally see!
I'm so scared!
He's shooting wherever the other people are shooting.
Let's kill him!
Let's fight back!
Oh my god.
Let's fight back with our bows and arrows!
I hit somebody, but I'm pretty sure it was friendly fire.
I'm pretty sure.
What can we do?
We have bows and arrows!
One's down here, where?
Oh shit!
I didn't bring bandages.
Bro, what if I just take a gun?
Do you have any meds?
No.
I'm gonna go back, I'm gonna go back.
Where did my teammates go?
Yo, someone loot down below!
Loot down below!
Go loot down below, someone!
Isn't there a guy below?
Someone go loot that guy!
Okay, I'm going, I'm going.
Loot him!
He's right there.
I got a headshot and it's friendly.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
I hit him!
He headshotted!
The headshot hit the fucking teammate!
Okay, that's pretty funny.
What?!
I can't tell who's the...
I can't tell who's part of the team and who is a bad guy!
I can't tell!
I can never tell!
They all look the same!
I can't tell who's bad and who's good!
Give me, give me, give me.
Mendo, Mendo, Mendo, where are you?
Mendo!
Oh my god, war is confusing!
I can't tell!
Everybody has guns!
Oh
my god.
Stay away from me!
Get over here!
You have, you have stuff!
Well, okay, they need to fucking aim better though, not gonna lie.
They're a fucking suck!
I didn't know if it was good or bad until I saw Blush fucking stone him!
And I was like, oh, I got a stone back!
I got a stone back!
Are they bad or good guys?
Well, let's find out guys!
I'm gonna take his clothes.
I saw the church people, so then I knew they were okay.
I knew the church people are okay.
Oh my god, there's so much bloodshed!
There's so much blood!
When will war end?
War is hell.
Oh my god.
They're just here for fucking blood!
They're not even here, all they want was blood!
They're just here for fucking, they're just here for corpses!
They're not even here for like, a purpose!
How do we get there?
Where's, how do we get inside?
Okay, last time I was inside, we flew in with a giant bird.
Oh my god.
How do we get in?
We just keep going round and round and, oh there it is!
I have 6 HP, let's see how long I live!
Wait, I got you, I got you!
Oh, sorry.
I tried.
No!
Guys, I tried, I tried, I tried!
I did!
I'm gonna use the bathroom, I'll be right back!
Oh my god, when?
War, war never changes!
Oh my god, war, war never changes!
How are we still fighting?
Oh my god.
If your jobs are not working, remember to link your, remember to link your Twitch account to your Steam account.
Oh my god, I hope nobody shoots me while I stand in the center.
I hope...
I hope, I hope nobody shoots me while I stand there.
What?
Oh my god, they even got Johnny Guitar!
Wasn't he just a music player?
They drafted him to the war too?
He was just... I feel like a journalist right now, I'm covering a war.
Johnny Guitar, I need to grab a cocktail.
Good job.
They even got the music guy?
I think he's with us, are you?
Who are you over there?
He's part of us, he's part of the team!
Yeah, you're with us.
You're with us, he's with us.
We're from the church, we're from the church and we're with Coco.
Yeah, we're with Coco.
I don't know where to shoot!
What's going on?
Don't shoot!
I don't know how this...
We know you're friendly, we know.
Biz!
Oh my god, I'll never find my old...
Please, stay safe around the troops.
Okay!
I don't have anything, though!
Aiden, you got any meds?
I'm right behind you.
I lost it all!
Thanks, dog.
Alright!
There's a bunch to your 230, Aiden.
Like, quite a few.
I'll take the pads.
Yes, keep spamming that shit.
Keep going, keep going!
Is there anything...
Oh no!
Push!
They can't shoot us all!
Let me do it, let me do it, let me do it!
Oh my god, is that a rocket?
I'm a good shot.
They're gonna use a rocket launcher?!
I'm so low, I'm so low!
Rocket!
Holy fuck!
You got more ammo?
I need pistol bullets.
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
I feel like I'm playing Battlefield 3!
Is there anything?
Is there any... Oh my god, there's blueberries!
I'm gonna steal your clothes, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, I'm so sorry!
I need something!
Oh my god!
What?!
What is going on?!
That's good, baby.
I think I'm dying!
I'm going through a lot right now!
I don't have... I don't have a gun!
What if I just... Oh, I just wanna take that gun!
I feel like a journalist right now!
I'm just... I'm just...
I feel like... I feel like I'm just spectating!
Wait...
Oh, what?!
Bow!
Oh, no!
I was like, wait a minute, is he like, part of my team?
He has a bow!
And I was like, wait, no!
I was so confused!
I was like, wait a minute, no, we killed this guy before!
Aren't you part of the war?
This is Doki reporting live!
We called Doki reporting for the war!
He's just relaxing!
What is going on?!
When does the war end?!
Bros just chill like that!
Union rules!
He enjoyed that!
He's just chilling!
The father was just chilling!
Also, Serpentine, thank you for the 25 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
This is Doki reporting from the Great...
The Great Ted War!
Here we are capturing a live...
A live motivation music session!
In order to boost morale!
We are here with one of the many musicians from the war!
The bard!
The bard is here!
The song of war!
Wait, is that... are you friend?
We'll never know!
I don't know who's friend and who's not friend!
I'm heading back!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm scared!
I'm so scared!
Where the fuck... where are guns?!
Oh my god, where are...
Where are guns?!
Where are anything?!
Jesus Christ!
Is this a gun?
What am I holding?
Where is anything?
Where is any...
Oh my god, at least there's an arrow.
Why is it every time I press escape it fucking tells me out?!
I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you, I'm with you!
Who is this?
Oh my god, is there any form of weapon anywhere?!
Yeah, come here.
You need a weapon?
Come here.
Friendly, friendly, friendly!
Coming up, coming up!
What's up, guys?
Oh, thank you, thank you!
What's up, man?
Thank you.
Oh fuck, no, I just...
I literally just got it!
Where did I get shot from?!
I'm so mad!
I never got a chance to shoot a guy!
The first time I touched metal!
The very first time I've ever got a chance to touch a gun!
The one time!
So, I'm gonna fucking... I'm gonna fucking defect if I have to do this one more time.
I swear to god, I'm this close to defecting.
This war, this fucking war, I'm...
Oh my god, I should get journalistic immunity at this point.
I should just commit to being a journalist.
I don't even know!
I can't tell anymore!
When will it stop?!
I did!
The moment I picked up a gun, my journalistic immunity stopped!
What the fuck?
I'm just a meat shield.
I am!
I am just a meat shield!
I need the press badges!
Oh wait, that's not Ted?
Why is there a fucking bear?
Why is there a bear here?
The wall, the wall 300 is not us, I don't think.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, what's up?
Holy shit, man, who are we shooting at?
Wait, they changed the arm.
Where's the enemies?
It's a sign.
It's a sign for me to...
Okay, we can go back.
What's going on?
I'm trying to head back to my people!
This has been a crazy war.
This really has been a crazy...
Oh,
that's them.
That's them.
That's them over there.
That's them!
You think they saw me?
I don't think they saw me.
I... I don't think...
Oh my god, they almost saw me.
They almost saw me.
No, I was not gonna use my rock against those people!
They're fucking animals!
I was not gonna survive.
And you know it.
You fucking know I was not gonna survive.
What's going on?
Oh!
Oh my god, he broke his own car!
He broke his own car!
I don't have the car!
What's going on?
Don't let him in!
Don't open it!
Do not open!
There's too many!
There's goddamn zombies out here!
Coral!
The walkers are everywhere!
I can't!
I need my revenge!
He had a car!
I have to be... I have to be careful!
I didn't want him to run me over!
I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's going on anymore?
Wait, I...
Oh shit!
Just get in!
Okay, lock it, lock it!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Drive!
What's going on?
I feel so scared!
Let him come over, Chip!
He's right there!
I didn't even...
No!
They destroyed the beds!
They actually destroyed the beds!
Oh my god!
Fucking madmen!
We'll go to Hannah Montana.
War is over.
I didn't... I was... I didn't want him to look at me!
He had a gun!
I was hoping he didn't see me!
Alright.
Back to...
Oh.
I'm trapped here.
I forgot this.
I don't have his password.
I don't have this guy's password.
Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
Goodbye.
I can't live my Hannah Montana life.
I can't live my...
I gotta go back to progressive Valhalla.
But we're not even part of Valhalla anymore!
We're not even...
They destroyed... They destroyed our beds!
Those fucking monsters!
Yeah, they did!
Those monsters!
We will... We will rest.
Holy fuck, I'm tired.
Guys, what were we even fighting for in the end?
What was the whole point in the end?
They attacked us first!
We... We were at their house.
I just wanted to live the simple life, man.
What...
What was it even for?
What was it?
Yeah?
They destroyed our beds!
What did they do?
Oh my god.
From who?
Today?
Is he coming?
Are the gods coming today?
Oh...
Yeah...
Sorry, Odin...
Odin requires two to three business days, guys.
Oh...
Guys, we got...
We didn't invest in Amazon Prime.
We didn't invest in Odin Prime, guys.
Sadly...
Sadly, we don't have Odin Prime.
So...
We just have it for two hours.
Alright, let's just grab some supplies.
And like explore a little.
I'm done with war.
I'm done... I'm fucking done with war.
Which one was the food?
Okay, there it is.
Alright.
And then...
The arrows.
No same day... No same raven delivery, sadly.
We don't even have arrows!
Guys, the AK doesn't unlock until tomorrow, guys!
I'm gonna grab a horse.
We have so many horses, guys.
Like, one horse gone wouldn't matter.
That's fine.
We've had a long day.
We had a very...
We had an incredibly long day, guys.
So it's time.
It's time to head off and travel.
But what if it's someone else's horse?
It's fine.
There's no... No.
There's no...
Today's a bad day.
Today's been a bad day.
It wasn't meant to be.
It wasn't.
It's a sign from the gods.
That today was gonna be a bad day for Doki at Rust.
Can't believe.
Can't believe all of that happened today.
I guess we'll just walk.
You know what?
Let's go gambling.
That's what I've wanted to do this entire time.
Nice.
I wanted to go... I initially logged in.
I initially logged in to fucking go gambling.
And I'm gonna fucking go gambling.
Yeah, I just got four dollars.
That's all I wanted.
My fucking side quest took me out of gambling.
But the side quest was over.
I can finally go gamble.
Instead of... Instead of gambling my scrap.
I'm gambling... I had to gamble my life.
For some fucking guy named Ted.
Of all things.
And then just to have him be gunned down.
Just like that.
I could've just done that in the beginning.
I could've literally just killed him.
Alright, time to gamble.
I got one guy.
What a fucking war.
The war... What a fucking war.
I touched a... I got to touch a gun for one second.
And then the god smited me down.
I bet Sykkuno's stream was super chill compared to what I just went through.
His Drops Adventures was so much more chill.
I fucking woke up to a fucking war.
Alright, let's head... I'm starving.
God damn it.
Alright, nice.
I woke up and just got drafted.
Just like that.
I just got drafted.
They didn't even know what I signed up for.
They pulled my name out like it was fucking Hunger Games.
And then off I go to war.
There we go, I see the world.
I'm gonna kill this chicken.
This is you, Dragoons.
This is you.
I'm putting my anger out on you.
No!
It's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
I'm going to war.
I'm coming back with PTSD now.
I'm coming back with PTSD from the war.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, the casino's so far.
Why did we build a base so far from the casino?
PTSD is real.
Sorry, I thought you were one of the people I fought before.
I thought you...
I heard a loud sound and I thought I was transported back into the battlefield.
It was that bad, guys.
That was how bad it was.
Shouldn't have made that sound, Dragoons.
Alright.
Off I go.
I wonder if I'll ever see Mr. Zealand again.
Mr. New Zealand.
What the fuck is this?
Is this the Iron Throne?
I should...
Wait, this is the Iron...
My throne now.
I was the true...
The real queen.
Where is everyone?
They're back at...
They're back at base here.
They're having another meeting, I'm pretty sure.
And then there's Ted and Dak in here fucking, I guess.
It's like...
In the...
Either the Janet or the foolish home.
Whichever one it is.
Whichever...
Sorry.
Sorry, I meant like...
There's Ted and Dak doing what bros do.
I mean, there's a fucking whole meeting with the Lurklings here.
And it's somehow Dak and Ted are here.
So like, just bros being bros.
Oh wait, what?
Is this Military Town?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's Military Town.
That's fine.
A little radiation doesn't hurt anybody.
It's fucking fine.
It's just a little radiation.
Look what happened to Spider-Man!
They're strengthening their bonds, exactly.
A little radiation made him into Spider-Man.
Made him into fucking Bear-Man.
That's fine.
It's raining anyway.
I'm just grabbing scrap for my gambling addiction.
That I'm gonna start now.
I'm gonna start my gambling addiction today.
I'm...
You all know when to start.
And today's that day.
Today's that day where I'm gonna start my gambling addiction.
Alright.
Never too late to start, exactly.
Never too late to start.
I heard how fun gambling was.
In-game, by the way.
In-game.
What do you mean I have a problem?
I literally started today!
Wait until tomorrow when I actually do have a problem.
Okay.
Here we go.
Whoa!
Oh my god, you scared me.
It's all good.
It's usually me getting scared.
Oh, are you collecting scrap for your gambling addiction too?
Oh no, I'm not a wheelhead, but I get it.
Wait, is that what they call them?
I'm collecting for the blood god.
Yup.
Wheelheads?
You know what?
Yup, you probably need it a little bit.
Oh, nevermind.
There's 22 and then there's a stop sign.
I'm not a wheelhead.
I swear, I'm not a wheelhead.
I'm just starting today.
The blood god loves you nonetheless.
That's a gift from him.
I swear, I don't have a problem.
It's just one, right?
If I do it once, it's not a sin.
Just one spin.
That doesn't make me a wheelhead.
Are you doing your free time?
No, no, surely not.
I mean, to be honest, once you start to get looking like that train wreck fella...
I mean, he's more than a wheelhead.
Wait, what is he?
There's something beyond wheelhead?
Like, you know how we...
He's... I mean, he is the head of house DJing claw.
I mean, you really couldn't name him anything more appropriate than just a downright, dirty, degenerate, slot machine, odds gambling lover.
But, you know what?
Despite all those words that the blood god has, we don't judge him.
Blood god loves all.
Is that right?
Y 'all got blood on us.
Even for train wreck.
Yup.
Yeah, I thought his blood got replaced.
I heard his blood got replaced by other substances.
You think he's got, like, silver and gold?
Yeah.
Just little things that he can extract and sell so he can spin that wheel one more time?
Exactly, how would he be able to keep spinning?
Have you ever looked inside his body?
It would make sense that he's selling his body.
Yeah.
Yup, yup.
Yeah, that's how, I mean, who keeps, how is he getting all that scrap to spin that wheel?
Gotta be selling his body.
The blood inside of him, the gold, I don't know, I don't know what he does.
But you know what?
Even if he does all that, it's still love.
Just like we love you, even though you might be a wheelhead.
But you might not be.
Nobody's saying it.
Only you know.
Yeah, yeah, and I know in my heart...
You think the blood god was angry?
Why was he angry?
Science men, they're trying to spread their word of logic.
Truth is what they say, but between you and me, we all know that's bullshit.
Vaccines, math.
Yeah, like how the plague isn't real.
I know, that's why we don't wear masks, right?
Wait, but you're wearing a mask.
Yup.
So, you believe then.
I'm trying to...
Take off your mask.
Yup.
Oh!
Oh, come on.
Wait.
Drop your shit.
We were just murdering together.
We were having a conversation.
Oh, you want to see my dumbass peanuts, don't you?
I need food.
Do you have food?
What about some cloth?
Cloth!
I don't have...
I have...
I just have one.
Take some of that.
Cheers, bitch.
Oh, shit.
You need a bandage?
You shot me in the...
Yup.
I'm alive!
Wow!
It's been a wild...
It's been a wild two hours.
The journalist doesn't die.
It's all about...
Journalistic integrity.
Reporting live on...
Reporting live in Rust Kingdoms 2.
A true survivor.
Oh my god, I went through so much.
I went through so much.
Alright, I gotta do...
I need to go through this way to get to the casino.
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
I left...
I survived to tell the tale.
The report...
Reporting live.
Alright.
Let's end it with some gambling.
At least I...
I got to keep my scrap.
Thank god.
Expecting trauma at every fucking turn.
It's a sign.
It's a sign, chat.
It's a sign that I must gamble with the scrap.
He died giving me the scrap.
I'm not a wheelhead, guys.
I'm not a wheelhead.
But he died giving me the scrap.
In his final words, he told me to spin that wheel.
Ooh.
Are you a wheelhead?
Alright.
How long you been here?
Spinning that wheel.
You just got here?
How much scrap have you spent?
Overall?
No, overall.
I'm curious.
This is my first day.
Spinning that wheel.
Wait, you can look at how much you spend?
8 ,000.
8,000?!
3, 3, 3.
Oh, oh.
I mean...
What's your...
That would be bad too.
Alright.
That's a wheelhead right there.
That's...
He warned me.
He warned...
I was getting my 30 scrap.
I had 30 scrap.
This guy was like, 3,000.
Oh, nice.
I got two.
Alright.
You know what?
All in.
Wait, we actually...
Plus one over here.
You know what?
The final spin.
Right here.
Guys, right here.
The final spin.
That man gave me his scrap.
For this very...
This very spin right here.
All in, babe.
What's the worst that could happen?
I lose it all and I fucking...
Slash kill?
No.
There's no way.
It's still going, guys.
There's still hope.
This is the longest fucking spinning wheel I've ever seen.
I hope Abby remembers this day.
I hope I traumatized Abby.
What a day.
I just changed the trajectory of their life.
I hope...
I hope Abby will remember this day.
Maybe she'll quit gambling too because of what I did.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
What a fucking wild, wild rest stream today.
I'm gonna try a new guerrilla stream when I'm away on my business trip for my concert.
But thank you everybody for coming.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I hope some of you guys managed to get your AK skin if you were here for the first two hours.
Sorry I couldn't stream longer today.
I had to pack and get ready.
I had to pack and get ready because I have an early flight.
So I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna have to leave now.
But anyway, guys.
I hope you guys all enjoyed watching.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I'm known for my FPS games.
FPS streams.
I used to be Top Islander and Apex and Overwatch.
Now I'm just a variety streamer.
I usually stream on YouTube so please check me out there.
I will announce my Rust Twitch streams on Twitter.
So please feel free to follow me on Twitter.
You wanna know when I'm gonna be live streaming Rust.
What else?
If you wanna support me via other means, I do have...
I do have GamerSubcode, Doki Bird.
Where you can get 10% off.
I have my merch, my PC case.
I have a custom PC case and custom keycaps with Hyatt.
So you can support me with that.
And then I have voice packs and everything at Doki merch.
And is that all my shilling?
Also, I love that you guys can nominate me for the VTuber Awards.
Nominate me for the VTuber Awards for FPS and Gamer of the Year.
It would mean a lot.
Yes, I would love to be nominated again.
But as me this time.
So yeah, here's the nomination.
I don't know if that... I have a command for that.
So I'm gonna put that here.
Anyway guys, I hope you guys managed to get your drops.
And I had a great time streaming today for you guys.
And I hope you had a great time watching.
As always everybody, stay high.
Also, I realized there's a VTuber kingdom too.
I bet it's so chill there.
Because I know there's a separate VTuber kingdom.
And I didn't see them in the war.
I literally didn't see them in the fucking war.
So...
Anyway guys.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause the check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
As always everybody, stay high.
Oh sorry.
As always everybody...
Oh my god.
I got lost in my fucking outro.
Wait.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
God.
War actually fucked me up guys.
Literally just ended.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I have to pack.
Plow.
Hey guys.
I guess I'll raid you to somewhere else.
I'll raid you to another rush streamer for a drop that you guys might not have got.
Sorry guys.
Anyway.
People who are in Plow's chat.
Hey.
I woke up to war.
And then like I died.
And I slash killed myself in front of the wheel to a wheel head.
Because I lost all my scrap.
That was how my story ended.
Anyway.
Hey guys.
I'm gonna send you guys off to somebody else.
I didn't realize Plow also ended his stream.
Hey guys.
Bye everybody.
Bye.
Also subscribe to me on YouTube.
For those who are like who the fuck is Doki.
I actually stream on YouTube.
So subscribe to me there.
And like I also have my own rest drop by the way.
So people who are like oh my god do you have anything.
I also have my own rest drop.
So like here is the gun you're missing out on.
Because you can't farm my rest drop right now.
Because I'm still.
I'm ending my stream.
Look at this gun that you can't get right now.
Because I'm gonna end my stream right now.
Sorry guys.
Next time.
I'll be streaming again next time.
Whenever I have time.
Alright.
Bye.
For real.